[Applause]
restaurant workers are being ripped off
say these protesters because they aren't
guaranteed minimum wage in 43 states
employers are allowed to pay tipped
workers less some as little as $2.13 an
hour that's not a wage it's barely
enough to buy a large cup of coffee
celebrities Plus Union protests
convinced voters and politicians in
several states that the government must
insist on a higher minimum for tipped
workers this would be more fair for all
workers specifically for minorities and
women they always say that it's to help
minorities and women
how is everything today but waitress
Elsie la Philippe is a minority and a
woman coffee
she says don't change the rules on - we
have a spaghetti and meatballs thanks to
tips I'll CLA makes much more than
minimum wage I'll make $25 an hour by
the end of the year I made around 48 to
50 thousand dollars take this for you if
you raise the minimum wage it will be
harder for restaurants to keep the same
amount of employees no no say the
so-called Public Interest lawyers we
have to have a law the problem with tips
is that they're very inconsistent law
professor to call Hallett leads social
justice protests this one demanding that
tipped workers repay that higher minimum
wage require restaurant owners to pay
the same hourly wage that all other
employers have to pay but many
restaurant workers say don't raise the
minimum a higher minimum threatens our
jobs the cost of having a restaurant is
not cheap for my boss to pay all her
employees that you have to cut employees
the boss boy will be cut Hallet is
unconvinced I simply don't believe that
increasing the minimum wage for tipped
workers will lead in a reduction in the
the restaurant workforce studies have
shown that restaurants have been able to
bear those costs
someone has to clear the plates but in
New York after the last minimum wage
increase 270 restaurants closed
John's always close the industry is
doing just fine restaurants don't always
close Michael Saltzman works for an
employer group that fights minimum wage
increases
yeah there's turnover in the industry
but what we're doing now is we're taking
an industry where there's low profit
margins we're dramatically increasing
labor costs and we're jacking up
restaurant closures if in the Bay Area
you've got a 14% increase in restaurant
closures for each dollar increase in the
minimum wage something's not right
that isn't right but the media is all
about workers who are unhappy and go
home with no money I don't think that
it's fair for a worker to struggle to
pay rent to struggle to make groceries
one study found that 46 percent of
tipped workers nationwide rely on public
benefits like food stamps but even how
it admits many are only eligible because
a lot of people don't report to income
many restaurants and restaurant workers
often don't report the final percent of
varying benefits doesn't mean anything
it just means that they're cheating the
taxpayer I'll see Ellie says she doesn't
cheat but many other people do lots of
people make cash money tip only tons of
restaurants do that have a great day
those who demand higher minimums also
plain eliminating tips will reduce
sexual harassment another argument
embraced by the media 90% of restaurant
workers report experiencing sexual
behavior that is scary or unwanted 90%
tipping is pretty dependent on her
willingness to touch or be touched this
will reduce sexual harassment sexual
harassment has nothing to do with the
state's tipping system and it's not me
saying that is the federal government
saying that a study using federal data
did find that states that raised the
minimum actually had increases in sexual
harassment the states that did what you
want there are more charges of sexual
harassment sexual harassment is a very
complicated problem and no single policy
is going to eliminate that problem ok so
raising the minimum probably won't
affect sexual harassment but it will
force some restaurants to fire workers
and for some to close
since prices will be higher tips will go
down this is supposed to be good for a
restaurant workers no wonder so many
opposed what the activists demand just
keep as it is we're fine who are those
people have they worked in a restaurant
industry
she hasn't and all this makes me ask why
should there be any minimum what get the
employer and the employee make whatever
deal they want well that that policy has
been rejected it's it's a something that
has been rejected for the last hundred
years and and we're not in that world
right now
we sure are ik we're in a world where
activists and government protect workers
even when they don't want that
protection